let's be like alright boys that's it
that's all I want to do with right bored
I would've been like what man this rash
man 29 old ass man oh hell no man I
would be proud of myself if I put the
Soylent people like yo who produce that
beat like yeah it's you got a grind you
got to work for something just take the
whole idea like I'm better than you like
we're all like the same every artist
from Tupac Eminem jay-z fans did it yeah
I do whatever the hell I want if I if I
don't do it cuz I didn't want to do it
they might laugh at me or think I'm
weird and it's like know that this is
what makes you you I wear white contacts
and all this stuff and it looks
ridiculous but it's still my image never
go for [ __ ] you never go for
[ __ ] he's an American rapper record
producer director and actor from Los
Angeles California he was he's well
known for his use of white colored eye
contacts in music videos performances
and interviews he comes in and here are
his top ten
you got to be more than one thing these
days if you're a rapper child learn to
produce or try to learn to manage
yourself or try to learn how to do
social networking online try to learn
how to book shows for yourself learn
something don't just be let's be like
alright boys that's it that's all I want
to do with write bars nothing else [ __ ]
I don't like that because then it's like
oh you're not really going to go
anywhere because you're not going to
find a manager he's going to want to
deal with you if that's really all you
do and it's going to be difficult to to
get anywhere when you're trying to reach
success you can't think of the long term
like when you just got it you just got
to go day to day and enjoy for the
moments that don't look at the next
minute compared your store to his going
thing he did it in this or he got that
and I'm still over here like you just
got to do it day to day if you got to
fans will really work that system of
those two fans and turn before ya make
it four then eight and then just keep it
going and then over the course of a few
years you know you just got thousands
and millions of fans and and yeah you
just got to enjoy day to day and just
put that work in because yeah if you got
told me when I was I wanted at 17 to 18
years old that's when I really wanted to
be on to be where I'm at right now and I
would have been able to handle it back
then but if you had to tell me like man
you ain't go be poppin you ain't go
beyond hot 97 to you 29 [ __ ] out of it
like what man this rash man 29 old ass
man oh hell no man I would I want to do
something else
but now but I'm when I look back at it
like I went through so much training of
learning how to rap you know and and you
know you I have my own little dreams at
the time like okay it's 2000 it's 2005
I'm about to do this I might be poppin
on myspace I'm gonna do this thing it
didn't happen but you just keep going
and you know you you makes you fail a
lot of times but eventually you just you
love this day yeah exactly
yeah so yeah you just got to put that
work in man look at your day to day last
year I was gonna retire before I had
announced it but then I decided to do
the new album pound syndrome and um I
put the whole retirement stunt but the
reason I wanted to do pound syndrome was
because I wanted to I want to make the
cell I've always produced all my office
but I just want to make a self-produced
album to where the products
just keeps getting over and open I want
to make that album that just like does
something crazy to the industry was like
yo he dropped that but I want I want to
produce it myself
so I can't people always like won't you
go the producers man once you admit you
you could be biggest is it's because I
won't be satisfied if I have a song on
the radio that's really huge if I didn't
make it only because I've been producing
since like I started rapping so and I'm
learning and I'm learning things all the
time just about quality and all that and
the art of like mixing songs and all
that so and these are things that didn't
know more on my past album so that
there's flaws in my production but this
album I stepped it up a little bit more
so you know I'm hoping that people can
can notice that and if not I'm gonna
keep on doing it but I will not stop
until I produce a whole entire project
myself because I thought that will make
me happy if I'm going I did all that in
my bedroom doing that just blew up and I
did everything in my bedroom that that's
what makes me happy so some people just
wanna be famous out of the fame the
famous thing like that's that's not
really gonna make me I'm not gonna be
proud of myself yeah I will be proud of
myself if I produce oil and people like
yo who produce that beat who did [ __ ]
the production on that that album was
fine who did you in and I just wanna be
like it's just mean I'll just go in the
room and just do it and just come out
with it so that that's gonna that's
going to satisfy me so that's why I
decided to go another round um and put
this new album out I believe in like
like funk volume if we if we start
working with an artist they do have to
be grinding somewhat just but it's they
don't necessarily have to have a million
fans on Facebook and all that it's just
they got we got to be able to see that
they have been working so there's a guy
who just dope that rapping and he's
never been the studio and he just has
stuff on the paper and he might have the
sickest punchlines but it's gonna be
like you don't have any studio
experience and you I don't know how
you're going to be if you're willing to
promote yourself online and being on
Twitter be on Instagram being on
Facebook chatting with fans like you and
and that this is a bare minimum
everybody should should have the
internet by now I know I mean like yeah
it's you got a grind you got to work for
something you gotta everybody should
have at least little cheap ass
microphone and a recording with because
I've been doing it in this room since I
was like 14 years old making little
trying to make it work I would get I
would deal the computer if I have to
build computers as well but with a
computer get a $1 microphone and Walmart
downloader program whatever
you'll find a way if you really really
want it if you're hungry but um so we
signed people who who where you can see
that they've been working so if they
have a couple videos out if you see that
their Twitter is always active there's
okay
at least they're working so we can go in
and enhance that now but we won't work
with somebody who just doesn't do
anything and they're just flat-out dope
even and not doing anything because it's
like you might you might hold us back
you might it because that means we have
to do more work and we already do a lot
so we look for artists who are already
grinding everybody does something great
it may not be music but I don't know why
it's like society just goes there
celebrities let's love them more than we
love ourselves and praise them and give
them all our attention and get nervous
when we get around them like not dude
like cuz I'm like real with it like I
can meet an artist down there many of
you if you pulled out a pencil start
drawing and you were really good I'll be
like damn like i'll be i'll be i'll be
talking you like yo damn dude that's
dope
I don't even doing it here hey like it
cuz I cuz I find it impressive I'm not
not just wanted like praise a celebrity
like oh my god you're in a movie I Tom
Cruise while dude here and then just
ignore another somebody else who did
something great who's not a celebrity
like I show love to anybody who does
something great um just take the whole
idea of like I'm better than you like
we're all like the same like just
interesting with at the end a it's just
a job and I go on take a look in the
frigerator see what it there is to eat
and just sit and watch Family Guy going
that flicks and fall asleep and yeah I
don't like making myself singing I like
Lamborghinis hot swimming pools in the
backyard barbecues all day like that's
not my life at all a lot of people sleep
on that like they don't they don't
understand how big the internet actually
is like and how much you can change
somebody's life like it it changed my
whole entire life completely like if the
internet didn't come around I'd still be
on Interscope trying to shot my demo
like that yeah yeah exactly and I used
to do that and but it's changed so much
now but I still see artists like a man
take my demo like dude they're like let
me rap for you and it's like that's not
going to like you okay everybody can rap
everybody has a dope 16 I take this from
now but it is more than that now like
what is your social media game
like how how much are you wanted howhow
are you running yeah yeah and um and
what artists to understand what kind of
upsets me is like I think they want they
want cosines and approvals by people
with and I had to understand that that
that didn't have to be the way so like I
said I would have loved to get a major
deal back in the day but I start to
understand like at the end of the day
the whole music industry everything is
about the fans they are the ones that
keep you guys live they're the ones that
keep my label alive every every artist
from Tupac Eminem jay-z fans did it so
these big guys P Diddy whatever it's
fans that made these people it's not
these these guys wake up in the
corporation yeah yeah you look at any
fortune 500 big company it's your Sumer
behavior and consumer and your
hard-earned money ya got went into
making these things as big as they are
exactly so and I start to understand
like if you can have a direct connection
with the fans then why do I need this
guy to cosign me I put me RB next to
this guy when the fans already with me I
just have my whole plan laid out and
yeah I do whatever the hell I want
if I if I don't do it cuz I didn't want
to do it so these labels don't impress
me
I am the label now I am labeling them
whatever my facebook everything I run I
just do whatever I want and I and I
still get the same amount of exposure as
these even sometimes more exposure than
a lot of these people in these big
labels when they put stuff out and the
label doesn't know how to promote it or
build a buzz and I'm just over here
sitting right here drinking this goddamn
cranberry juice posted on Facebook and
just gets a million views fast and it's
just they're just like how do you do
that
Wow how does he do it because I built it
organically and learn how to rap I talk
to my fans I'm a humble dude I um yeah
just just building everything from the
ground up not sugarcoating anything I'm
not being fake about anything I'm not
putting on a fake image I'm not having
other stars cosign me or being next to
people just like I look cooler and
making people think that I'm dope than
what I am it's just it's the realness
I'm just hops in the guy who knows how
to rap and I be online promoting myself
and I started this career and
I got my little team with phone volume
and we're all doing it everybody is the
same and I run into these people I feel
like we like I nobody is a real real
individual any like uh it's rare that
you stumble across someone who's a real
individual when you do is like amazing
is I and I love seeing people who are
just truly themselves but everybody is
like whatever they see on TV whatever
they see around and they just want to be
that it's like you don't world is huge
you don't have to be that you do not
have to be what what your neighbor is do
you have to do what your neighbor is
doing you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want so people are just like yeah
rappers feel like they have to be a
certain way actors feel like that be a
certain way people in certain
neighborhoods like that if you're
certain wakers who they're around and I
know deep down like um like children
children are themselves they react off
of instinct until they start to
understand how the world is yeah and
human I mean an adult's when once they
turn into an adult there they start to
see like oh dang okay I can't do that I
can't like that number I can't I can't
be that way because that's that's not
acceptable because I'm like it I might
look down upon they might laugh at me or
think I'm weird and it's like not that
this is what makes you you this is what
makes you you like I I just try and it's
hard to do I've don't get me wrong like
I'm I'm still learning about myself I'm
trying to just um open myself up to new
ways of thinking all the time and just
truly be myself but sometimes I get
caught in something that makes there's
so many different levels to a matrix you
know saying you do sometimes you like
them I thought I was out and I was still
in like it is just but um that's right
but yeah it's just everybody it feels
like they have to be just like everybody
else and when I when I see rappers I'm
like come on doing it you'll see you
dance same dance doing the same turn and
it's like do you got you got a billion
tattoos on your face and body where did
you get that from because you I know you
didn't come out of your mom's vagina
going I want to be tatted you saw
somebody do that and you said I want to
do that too because that's gonna make me
look like this type of thing and I want
to be just like that I'm and everybody's
doing it I know that works so I'm gonna
do it and now it makes you look like one
of them and now you're now you're not
original and then your rap career
doesn't go for you like well what
happened and then it's just in it but
it's not just rapping it's just just all
areas of life what is the thing that
Hopson learned that set him apart from
the next dude who could rap just as well
as Hopson
well I say you you can't you can't be
afraid to make a fool of yourself
because I'm not so um if I you got to
analyze everything so um even the
artists I study every artist that's like
popping even ones who are even ones who
aren't popping you got to study
everything so don't just hate if there's
an artist you hate and who's not popping
just study every detail like why is he
not popping why did this not work for
him look at the artist where something
is working like I don't like a lot of
swaggy tight rap but I still see things
like when when it's popping on the
internet and people are really with it I
try to understand why like what is it I
look at all these major details even
when it comes to videos like the colors
that they use like man this is a video
it's not really my style but I can see
what what it's doing to my brain when
I'm watching it to make me interested in
this so I'm like okay maybe I need to
apply colors to certain video my videos
to do something that way even when it
comes like images of important thing
it's not just bars you have to
understand that it's not just bars I
sound like I'm freaking weird mad
scientists right now in China not
anymore
yeah it's not what you just have bars
like that's not that's not enough to do
it this image and I have an image my I
wear white contacts and all this stuff
and it looks ridiculous but it's still
my image I still had I didn't start out
doing it this way I had to realize like
okay this is this is the route that I
want to take his crazy and weird but I
did my homework and this is going to
work for me and every artist has their
own thing you know
um sure DMX when he was like I want to
start barking uh like he didn't even
start midnight maybe he had to come up
with that he hadn't realized like that
that's what I failed you this is what I
do like in my name with this blonde hair
like you come it comes to a point where
you got to realize image image plays
apart 50 cent with the whole bulletproof
vest thing when he first came out you
have to have an image you can't just be
you you can be a normal guy but you have
to realize that okay my image is going
to be a normal guy I don't like that is
that is what I'm going to present myself
as and because yeah when you're just
normal guy and you're not you're unaware
that you're normal guy you just want a
regular t-shirt or whatever and and you
just need to select like I got bars and
that's and that's all you got it's not
enough you have to analyze yourself what
do you look like how are you coming off
it's not just about bars it should be in
a perfect world we would just listen to
your lyrics but that's not what it is
every step I take in life I always think
about tomorrow something like how is
this kind of tomorrow is this going to
is this going to [ __ ] up tomorrow for me
or is this just going to be something
that I'm going to do right now and I'm
able to drop it tomorrow net not even it
won't even affect tomorrow
some people don't give like oh I'm
watching colder there's that and then
tomorrow I'm coming around and so and by
tomorrow it could be a week later a year
later it's just that one day that that
night whatever you decide to do
something it just now it's impacted your
whole life to where every day you wake
up it's there now whatever you did could
be herpes could be a kid could be you're
in prison could be something it's just
like I don't move like that I move where
it's like let me take this next step is
this step going to be up tomorrow for me
if it is I'm not going to take it and
then some steps where it's like okay I
know this is kind of a bad step it's a
little on the dark side but it's not
gonna [ __ ] up tomorrow so I'll do it you
know I'll do this it's not you know let
me go yellow for it for the night and it
won't it won't come tomorrow for me and
I'll be cool you know you never you
never go for [ __ ] you never go for
[ __ ] the is true you never go full
[ __ ] do not come tomorrow because
tomorrow is what tomorrow is what your
life depends on you may not be depending
on it but the you and the future is like
please man don't get up maybe it's all
on you man and then and then you now
sometimes like I would give a big I've
turned it up and then it's like damn and
then now you're 34 years old like uh did
that and in it you know I like that's
why I like rappers like Macklemore it
makes you think it makes you not want to
be stupid when you listen to music you
actually want to be better you don't
want to be you only go out just be like
I'm emotion I'm gonna go through this
I'm gonna go be ups now you don't do
that and you know I'm not trying to be
all extremely positive it it excites
humans to be bad sometimes some people
want to go and have a one-night stand so
if you want to go get drunk some people
want to go smoke I understand that I
have my little bad things that I want to
do too but never go full [ __ ] it
that's just what it comes down to
don't let your don't let your cups of
today are the little darkness that you
do in today cross over into tomorrow
because that's when it's like yo you
dumb now that that's you did last night
these mom knocking at my door now
they're trying to kill me or they're
trying to do this in are they
whatever don't let it cross over to the
next day just leave it at that
leave it leave it there is be
responsible and just move on from that
moment thank you so much for watching we
made this video because unequal access
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want to profile next leave in the
comments below and we'll see what we can
do which one of this happen Bruce thank
you so much for watching
believe I'll see you soon got the porter
freaking made happening behind